okay let's do this one more time so
tenet is a film i've seen
up down left right and inside out
boy you turn me like the characters in
the movie it's only upon going through
the events of it several times that i
start to see things from a new
perspective
and the more i watch it the more it
becomes clear that cat
is actually the future protagonist we're
gonna be going through all the clues in
this video but if this is your first
time here then welcome to the heavy
spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka the coolest cat
when it comes to tennis
now let's get into the breakdown okay so
this train of thought first came to me
on my 7th and 97th watch of the film
during the scene in which the
protagonist encounters priya for the
first time
upon reverse bungee jumping into a home
he initially believes that her husband
sanjay singh is the weapons trader
that's been dealing in munitions
however it's revealed that priya is
actually the one behind this
and she says the line a masculine front
in a man's world
often has its uses this sent me
spiraling off into thinking that it
could indeed be the case with the
protagonist
and just like how sanjay is the face of
his operation
it could go far beyond that in the other
characters now i think from the way that
pre-acts and the things that she says
that she has at some point interacted
with the future version of the
protagonist
she has an air of arrogance to her about
the events that are going on
and doesn't seem to respect the
character at all even disobeying what he
says at several points
now if she was aware that he would be
the overseer of tenet
then surely she would respect and fear
him more
this got me thinking what if the
protagonist is actually controlled by
someone
and he is simply being used as a
masculine front to hide what's going
on that made me really start to
deconstruct his actual character
and the more i thought about it the more
i realized he doesn't really fit the
mold of the god like person that we hear
controls everything
throughout the film he has a little to
no agency at all and whether it's the
opening opera scene
being told what to do and whereby
michael crosby having neil keep him in
check and so on
he just doesn't seem to be the person
making decisions
even ive shows about nowhere and tells
him what to do
and he almost kills both neil and the
protagonist before changing his mind
i know this is him likely just playing
with the pair but the protagonist
doesn't really strike me as someone
who's good at making choices
in fact most of the times that the
character does take charge of something
it completely ends in failure let's be
honest now this is seen especially in
the highway chase in which he ends up in
a car crash
and he only manages to stop the
algorithm at the end from being buried
because neil sacrifices himself
the idea of him having no agency is
further hammered home and what could be
his opposite
aka sanjay during their meeting the
protagonist says that he's not the
person they sent to negotiate
and even admits to simply being a
trigger that people send to pull
like sanjay he's in place to do one job
but when it comes to making decisions
he's not the person people turn to
however
cat often is and there are several
moments that point towards her directing
him and even giving the character orders
during the school meeting scene she
tells him how to get into rotus
and come the end of the film she's
leaving him messages so that he can
protect her
not the other way around these orders
sent back to the past are similar to
what we see saito getting
and thus it's not too much of a stretch
to assume that the protagonist
is still just a trigger hell he even
kills priya at this moment
hammering home this idea that he still
only really has one job
now there's also a part in this scene
that we should also pay close attention
to
bria seems confused by the whole thing
especially because the protagonist is
showing up
the reason for this is because she knows
that there are really others behind the
scenes that aren't him
and this is confirmed by the line in
which he says there are multiple
protagonists
therefore we know that there are others
that exist who have controlled not only
her
but also the events that we see play out
in the film
now because of this like sanjay he could
very well just be the face of the
protagonists
the hired gun that is directed by the
others that lurk in the background
tenet works on the idea that there are
people controlling the events of the
movie that we don't see
and this is not only shown in the
protagonist but it's also
very much part of saitor's story similar
to what we see happening to the
protagonist at the end
satosh simply receives messages from the
future and then carries out what they
tell him to do
thus cat could very much be doing
something similar to the character
without him even knowing but what
exactly is the evidence for this
and what motive would she have for
sending orders back to the past
well cat's sole desire in life is to
protect her son
she knows that the protagonist is the
only man capable of doing this
and thus she likely manipulated things
behind the scenes
so that he would do this and save her
too other reasons that cement that she
is indeed one of the controlling figures
in the future
is because she knows the ins and outs of
sator's operation
because of their marriage she's had
access to sensitive information on his
organization
and likely knows intimate things about
it that the protagonist never would
she knows about where things go when he
started dealing ammunition
where his crew went to on jobs and so on
making her a far better choice
as the director of tenet because of this
knowledge
she could easily put the protagonists on
the right path for the events that we
see in the movie now there are other
things in the film that hint towards it
and the eagle eyed amongst you will have
noticed that the colours blue and red
are used throughout the film at several
points
these appear in the background of scenes
on certain objects and so on
they're the colors that the key teams
use to differentiate the past from
future with
and thus they should be paid attention
to however
as apparent as these colors are the only
character that we actually see
wearing them fully as part of their
clothing is cat who appears not only in
a blue dress
but also a red one i think that this is
nolan hinting to us
that we should pay very close attention
to her now if we continue this idea of
metaphors
and understand cat's arc then we have to
see that the journey she goes on
actually contradicts the idea that the
protagonist is looking over her
and not the other way around throughout
the film she is under her husband's
control completely
and it seems weird to me that she would
break free of this in the finale
only to fall back under the protagonists
now though he is looking out for her
it still sets up the idea that the
character has control over her life
this is really an opposite to her arc
and it's clear that the end of the movie
is meant to free her from control now
another hint towards this
i think is because she actually makes a
choice in the finale
though everyone tells her that she
shouldn't kill sato before they have the
algorithm
she does it anyway and gets her own way
even though others tell her not to
clearly she is not under the control of
anyone else anymore
and the fact that she's able to do this
without ending the world shows that she
has an almost godlike ability to control
things
and get her own way the algorithm was
supposed to detonate when satou's heart
stopped
and yet the fact it doesn't highlights
just how powerful kek can be seen as
now the other characters such as the
protagonist neil and ives
they're all on paths that they can't
divert from whereas cat making a choice
shows that she is above them i very much
view the ending as her being free from
her husband's control
and the way that she looks at her past
self on the boat before leaping
very much highlights to me that she has
come full circle and knows that she is
broken free of the hell
that she was trapped in it's very
triumphant moment
and in summary to me cat is actually the
future protagonist and the movie is
about her
saving her son in the world nolan is
often said that in the same way that
inception was his take on the heist
movie
that tenet is his take on this spy one
thus if we take the archetypes from that
and apply them to this
the protagonist is very much james bond
whereas
cat is m as priya says there are
multiple protagonists
and similar to her relationship with
sanjay the one we follow is likely just
a blunt instrument that carries out
orders for the others
cat has access to seito's in our
operations and also has a motive to make
sure he falls because of his
mistreatment of her
that's what you get for shooting her
mate she becomes free in the end because
unlike the other characters she makes a
choice and therefore
is the true future protagonist or you
know
might not be and that's the video ruined
but if you're someone who watches tenna
every week like me
then i'd love it if the next time you
went through it that you had this theory
in mind
the beauty of the film is that it's
different every time you go through it
and there are a lot of different
theories that you can really apply to it
i'd obviously love to hear your thoughts
on this one and
whether you agree with me or whether you
have just a completely different one
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw in which we're giving away three
copies of the hobbit and lord of the
rings 4k box set to our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the theory
the links to our socials are in the
description and you can also support the
channel by clicking the join button and
as a thank you you get videos like this
early
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
neil's journey at the end
and what happened to him at stealth12
it's linked on screen now
and it's definitely worth watching if
you want more tennis videos
without the way thank you for sitting
through this one i've been paul
you've been the best and i'll see you
next time take care
peace